Hello everyone.
Welcome to toxic Google on Kevin Belk.
And today we welcome Harrison
Ford for blade runner 2049.
Thank you very much.
Can we Google? Thank you very much.
Yeah. Well excited to have you here.
I'm excited to be here.
Yeah. So, uh, yeah,
so you're returning a role a that
you create over 35 years ago. Um,
it's the world and the characters
obviously changed a bit since 2019. Uh,
but when you were first
called to return to the role,
I have to mention me and
you. Yeah. Not Too much.
Plenty. No, no, no, no, no.
But, uh, no, no, no. But it, it,
so did you work with a,
the director and the writers?
A Hampton Fancher and Michael
Green on developing the character
drove where a decker does now?
Um,
you know, I worked more with
the Dinny, the director, uh,
the, um, and, and on the script, but, but,
but mostly I,
I filtered my input and,
um, concerns through Denny. Um,
I read the, uh, I read
the novella that, uh,
Ridley and Hampton French or one of the
original writers developed as a kind of
a exercise prior to the
script writing the script.
And I said, that's a, that would be good.
That would be good. And then, uh, then
when the script came, then I began to,
uh, work with, uh, with Tony.
I really wanted to establish my
connection to him. And was that, when,
did you have any concerns about
coming back to the character at all?
Not about coming back to the
character, just about, you know,
taking advantage of the opportunity to,
uh,
to get the most out of the potential that
there was in revisiting the character
after so many, so many years.
Yeah. It's, and it's incredibly difficult
to talk about the film, by the way.
So you'll see this with the questions
and because there's the plots,
basically a spoiler.
So it's,
is that difficult as you go through some
of this talking about the film and in
terms of not spoiling stuff?
No, no, you just keep it,
keep it simple.
I, yeah, I don't enjoy talking about
Marsha.
This should go great then for free.
How much it cost? Just going, oh, no,
no, no. I'm happy to talk, but you know,
I want to save it for the audience.
I want to serve for you guys.
I don't want to tell you what happens.
Why would you, why would you want
to it to read in today's newspaper?
What's going to happen tomorrow?
I mean, why would you go into a movie
if you knew how it was going to end?
Right.
Well, it's, and it's unbelievable. We
were talking off stage, you would call it,
I'd call it fucking epic.
I said,
can you say fuck here? And he said, yes.
I gave Harrison Ford permission to swear
yes, in that, that you need. If not,
then I do. You don't need
it. But there's a great cast,
Jared Leto and Robin Wright and, uh,
Ryan Gosling. So when Ryan Gosling, uh,
you know, him becoming a,
stepping into a blade runner role,
did you give him any advice on
what should be doing? I can know
and can seek the answer.
Man can play the piano.
He doesn't need any advice from me.
It's been a,
he was a mouseketeer.
Uh, no, I'm serious. He was,
he's been in the business as long as I am.
Uh,
and he's only half my age or less,
I think. Anyway, he's a, he's a
great guy to work with her. I had
the best time working
with them and I'm really
not that it matters,
but I like him.
No. Um, and you know, he, he's
phenomenal. And just the, the use of what,
what I found out about the film was the
use of practical effects and building
real sets and that we're laying a lot,
we're like allowing too much on CG,
but you've been in both
worlds in terms of,
you've worked a lot with
practical effects, but you've
also worked a lot with CG.
Do you like one over the other or do
you see any positives or negatives?
I think there's huge positive in
working in a physical space. Um,
uh, I mean, just sitting
here, I, I, I can,
I'm relating to the, this, you know,
the sound of my voice in this space.
I'm relating to the closeness of
the people in the front row. Uh, um,
I can smell something.
Don't,
was that you?
But
it's, it's, it's, it gives me
a sense of reality, uh, that I,
that I don't even think about
because it's there. And,
uh, so we, you combine
that with, with what the,
the visual information. When
you walk onto a set, you know,
it, for instance, there's
a set a scene in, uh,
in the office of the character
played by Jared Leto.
And I think it's no secret
that he's, it's a, it's a,
it's a, uh, a visual
environment that, that, um,
telegraphs power and, and, uh,
great on natural power and,
uh,
so that, that, that's communicated. Uh,
and a picture is worth a thousand words.
And so you,
you pick up from that point, you
know, it's not like, but you, you,
you can be a pre armed
with a, you know, a visual,
a CG storyboard that's going
to be supplied later, but
it's not exactly the same. You can't
bounce the sound off, uh, off, uh,
you know, a storyboard. Yeah.
And, uh, it's, no, it's a
great point. And you know,
you, you revisited this character of
Deca. And what's actually interesting was,
you know,
watching the original film,
which was super interesting to see how
head of its time it was as well with its
facts and its use of models.
And so I bought its predictions of a
scientific developments and that's why I
was feeling that that's the
part that blows me away.
The capacity that we have now to
create what we call
replicants medically possible,
uh, has, uh,
advanced far beyond
anybody's actual expectation.
Yeah. And, and, and you know,
today in this particular
environment where we are facing,
uh, people that, uh,
suddenly for the sake of
their own convenience,
I've chosen not to believe
in science anymore. Uh,
it's, it's pretty, it's pretty
important that we understand that,
uh, you know, what kind of logic,
reality science is
responsible for and that,
and the sort of moral story of the,
of the, that's that's
part of the, the film
is that it's only, uh, that our capacity,
uh,
to build a human being and then own it.
Because it's your intellectual
property. You know, not, it doesn't,
there's no free will, no free choice, no,
no human opportunity,
uh, no human potential.
But, but to have a program,
biological, uh, Lee,
I identical creature,
uh,
to a human being and to own it,
well that's what we used to
call it slavery. Uh, but, uh,
the,
it's only the moral constraint of
science that keeps it from happening.
I mean, we can, can create life
in a, in a Patriot journey.
We've agreed or petri dish and we
decided not to go much further than that.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
and this actually goes to one of the
questions we took questions from social
media and from Googlers.
And one of the questions was the original
1918 film predicted a lot technology
that we would have now and 20,
49 does some of the same where you
start seeing where technology could be.
And we're actually pretty close.
Um, so as life as imitating art,
artificial intelligence, toxic smog,
video calls, what lessons do you think
yeah,
of that world will be informed?
Like inform us on how to not
repeat mistakes or, well,
I mean, we know what not to do. And
so the message is don't do that.
Okay.
Can we turn the world into
a shit hole? And, uh, and,
and so don't do that
individually or as a
culture, as a, as, you know,
impose the positive nature of humanity on,
on the world instead of the
negative nature. Protect nature.
Nature doesn't need people.
People need nature to survive.
It's true.
I don't have a segue,
but, um, it was dark.
I'm sorry, but, uh, I know. Um,
but you revisited Deckerd and,
and now,
and then I'll Han Solo in Indiana Jones
and I'm sure a lot of people ask you
about which carrier you
want to revisit again,
but is there a character that you really
do love that you feel like their story
is closed?
You've moved on? Oh, there's
a lot of characters. I mean,
I don't have favorites.
Um,
I'd love the opportunity to,
um,
uh, to tell stories that, uh,
okay
with the audience wants to hear.
I would think it's a public service
occupation to be a storyteller.
We need that. We need those stories
to be told in a variety of different,
uh, styles, you know, uh,
movies,
music,
whatever you just, we, we need,
we need stories about ourselves to
inform us and remind us of our common
humanity.
Are there any films or,
or stories that you've read or seen
that I've done that for you? Well,
there are films that I've been in
have, well, we do it for me. Yeah.
I just got out of the car listening to
Albert King a song and I spent three
minutes.
They're making you lose weight because
nobody walks out an Albert King.
Uh, so yeah, but I get it
every day. I get it out of a,
I get out of a nod on the
street. I get it out of, uh,
out of Albert King I, you know. Yeah,
yeah. Was there a role
now? Thank you very much.
What was hope you're getting it back.
It's only fair.
Was there a roller character that you
felt once you found that character that it
can agree you as an actor or even as a
person there would like just Rumi as a
carry? Every one, every one
of us, every one of them.
Because you don't, well, for first
of all, you explore the life, right?
And the quality of mind of a character.
But you're also working with a
group of people, a new tribe,
every, you know, every movie is a
new bunch of people with new heads,
new, um, um,
it's a, it's just this,
uh, this process is, uh,
is really sustaining and engaging
and challenging and demanding and,
uh, it's, that's the part I really love.
What was there, is there anyone in,
this is probably hard for you,
but like is there anyone who you haven't
worked with before that you still want
to work with in terms of director or
actor or writers? Yeah. Yeah, sure.
Oh,
there was one oh one 10.
Oh Man, I don't know. No, I
just can't go there. I don't,
I don't know how to go there,
honestly.
Fair.
Albert King,
um, you know, you've
been in this film, it's,
it's very physically demanding
and there's a lot of, um,
stunts and physical work that you do
with Ryan and, and water and everything.
Um,
how did you approach again in,
in water is not quite
physically demanding. I had
a shower this morning. Yeah.
And that's what I'm talking, I'm talking
about the shower scene with me. Uh,
it was, you know, it's a, yeah,
there's some physical, I like physical
go acting. That's fun. That's
great. I love that kind of stuff,
but I, I did, this is not, there's
a, there's a bit, there's enough.
Yeah. But that's not the kind
of movie this is for me. Yeah.
I mean there's, uh,
yeah, there's good stuff.
Good action in it.
Yeah.
Is there, so we talked about kind
of the negatives with blade runner,
but is there any thing with a
technology or a piece of technology, um,
from the original blade runner or this one
like to see, become a reality? Uh,
I, Ryan keeps saying that
he wants a flying car. Um,
uh, but I fly or playing, so I know. Okay.
Okay.
You
don't need the flank. No, no.
You know,
I want us,
I want to see that technology
which will help the natural world.
Um,
and I,
I want to see our devoted as devote
our energy to making lives better and,
um,
promoting some kind of,
even
opportunity for people that
haven't had their shot yet.
Anything across all fields
against in terms of people have had
their shot, like, and Oh, I just mean,
I mean cultures, uh, that you know,
that maybe are going to get gobbled up,
uh,
to be somebody else's
breadbasket or, uh, um,
I'm concerned about, you know, what,
what we have done as,
as,
as one of the highest consuming nations
in the world and what we're asking the
rest of the world, uh, to
do, to now to save our asses.
Um, and, um, and I, and
I want to, you know,
I want to see the forces
at hand that keep us,
uh, um, from,
from really fully exploiting the
potential of alternative force, uh,
forms of energy,
uh,
because they've got such
a stake in fossil fuels
and that technology,
we better get on with it,
or a word or word
gone
skydiving.
Well, it's scary, but it's
also exciting. I mean,
I'm sitting down here and
I'm looking at all this, uh,
okay.
Suppose it brainpower and
an opportunity
and I can see who around here that
it, it's fun to go to work. Uh,
and so let's get other
people to get to work and,
uh,
yeah, get it done. Um, so a
few questions from a social,
um, so social media, which you love
right now, and a Google employees. Um,
but was there a, what was, do you have,
without going too much in the parlors,
was there a, the, what was the
most difficult scene for you?
The film we're challenging scene.
Nothing.
I love going to work on it and
I don't have anything difficult.
What was it as enjoyable seeing them?
Um,
oh wow.
It's next question with
the front of it is no,
the front of it is that it's
that in a certain sense you go uh,
armed with what you think is necessary.
Uh,
you identify the bit of story that
you want to create behavior around.
Cause every, every scene should
ever have a reason to be there.
You want to make sure you're not doing
the same thing over and over again,
sort of that kind of thing. You want to
be available there, but you also, uh,
for me,
I loved the problem solving aspects of it.
All of a sudden the director
wants a shot, you know, for,
to motivate the camera and the actor has
the camera's got to follow the actor.
What, why would I go out to
the other side of the room?
Little little stuff like
that or the dialogue isn't
really feeling authentic and
then w you know, what, what do you
do in, in collaboration with who,
with all of the other people
involved to just solve that problem.
Is there any, did you have any advice? I
guess that's the real fun of it. That's,
that's what, that's what makes
you feel good about the day. Yeah.
And it would,
do you have like a particular director
or someone you worked with were like,
you've got that from them
and you just remember it was,
this is a piece of advice that I will
carry through with all my other fellows.
Um, well I had, I, there was a,
there was a guy named Mike
Nichols who a great film director.
He was a half of nickels in May,
great stage director,
one of the smartest guys
I ever met. Um, and funny,
uh,
hugely funny guy,
but the occasion of one of my,
some early success,
uh,
or attachment to somebody else's success,
which is really what it's about,
a common success. He said, uh, to me, um,
don't let them turn you into a thing.
No, I don't still don't know
exactly what that means. No, do I,
but, uh, it'll come to you, uh, uh,
after all these years.
Well, I mean, you know,
somebody will approach you with something
that is not who you are or what you
want to be, uh, but has a utility, uh,
to them or a perceived utility to
them and that I'll call that a thing.
Great answer. Um, uh, another
question from social was,
so you were talking a little bit
about scenes and stuff like that. Um,
do you have an array or do you have a
preference between the original cut of
blade runner or of the original or
the final cut or the director's cut?
Any of the cuts that you like?
Did you read watch one,
I guess going into this dude,
I rewatch one of those. Yeah,
I rewatched, um, uh,
what Ridley called his director's cut or
was his final director's cut or is last
cut or the one after that? I don't, yeah,
we have no more money out of money,
which had happened, but it, yeah,
that, uh, I like it.
The a or the one without the voiceover
narration and the drive into the sunset.
I liked the one that ends with me picking
up the Unicorn and stepping into the
elevator and the doors closing now.
I don't know if that was still out there.
Yeah, no. Yeah, that
was all, I just want to,
I'd like to see that one and the new
imax format, but I haven't seen that.
Uh,
that would be,
that would be interesting to see
that what the visual changes.
Yeah. Um, so a few more from social. Um,
what should we expect of Deckerd and
his evolution with the blade runner
universe from the first film
to now 2049 expect nothing.
Spoilers. Spoilers. No. Um, oh,
I thought you were talking about does
it? Yeah. I believe you. This character,
let me leave it at that.
Expect nothing but just going go in cold.
Okay.
Um,
what was the first thing that you
thought when you found out what their was
going to be? A blade runner sequel. Well,
Ridley called me and um, so, uh,
would you in theory,
would you be interested in
revisiting the character?
And he's quoted as
saying that. I said, hmm.
Yeah,
which is bullshit. I said, I
said, yes, yes, I would, uh,
if, if, you know, if there's, if
I can figure out how to do it,
if I show me a script,
and that's when I got this a
novella that I talked about earlier.
Um, and how did, uh,
reprising the role of Dechert compared
to a returning as Han Solo or Indiana
Jones? It's just two different
things, but that's how they compare.
There we go. Two completely
different things. Okay. That's a,
that's an employee a question.
So that's all right. Not Mine.
Do not credit me with that.
Nothing wrong with the question.
Uh, that is the answer. Yeah.
They don't compare. Um, and
I'll, I'll leave it with,
if you had to describe
yourself with three words.
Okay.
Almost done.
There is no fourth way more now. You
weren't forward. No, it's all right. Um,
so thank you so much for
being here. Uh, blade runner,
2049 is a out next week on October six.
It is
awesome.
[inaudible].